This is of Clark and here for the Brooklyn public library our streets our stories project I'm joined
by Brenda that Peters and today we're talking to Sheila GALLAGHER We're
at the Dyker branch of the
library and I kind of start a little bit further back than I normally do because it's just out of
so many wonderful photos. So tell us a little bit about your parents and where they came
from OK My dad was born in clue numerable County early
term little town or village cauldron Kiernan and my mom was born in so
I go she was born in new cool in so I go
and
both all the terms and fly go or border counties they border each other but it wasn't
until many years later they met at a dance and Irish dance I guess in the
Bronx and that's how they ended up dating and getting together and
eventually marrying and eventually having me and my sister and how did they decide
to come over here.
I believe in my father's case I think one of his brothers was already here. And his
sister was here in a sense to him because in Ireland at that time the economy wasn't
so stable or you know and he was unable to get a job that he wanted and he felt
America would be a better choice for him that he would have more
opportunities and so he came out here and he worked into a number of odd jobs before he ended
up finally staying with the M.T.A. the transit
authority and he drove the bus here on seven day Avenue eight they have a new
line and he worked at a Jackie Gleason depot on thirty six Street which is that one of
the depots for vocal and my mom I believe her sister a Melba
the older one sent for her and she came out and she ended up working many years.
Seventeen years in
SRAM as a waitress and as a assistant manager and that was an
interesting job too
because one of the story she told me was about meeting Mamie Eisenhower.
She worked in traffic at the Chrysler Building and she also worked in the sheriff's in the White
Plains area. So one day. Manny Eisenhower came
in and requested tea. So my poor mother went and got a cup of
tea and brought it to her table and put it in front of her and said here is you see and Mamie
Eisenhower took one look at it and boy and said that is not
mighty Please go
back and get me my tea. So my mom brings back and one of the
waiters called her over and he
said I'll take care of her. So they went to the bartender and they had a
drink made up with a martini straight up and they put it in the teacup and brought it
back to the table and she said oh now you brought me my
tea and that was
how she learned that Mamie Eisenhower had an
interesting so I'm going in addition to being the general's wife she was also
later on became first lady when she was you know when Dwight David
Eisenhower became president but that's my mother's introduction to me
Eisenhower and her cup of tea. And then you
ventured a little bit about the
as well as a story with that while the dance I guess was in the Bronx
and at that time my dad had gone with an a lady named Peggy who Peggy
is lost in the annals of history but apparently Peggy followed my mother
into the ladies'
room and asked her for her phone number and my mother bought saying why would I give
you my phone number and she said it's for the guy outside Peter he wants to date
you and my mother said well you're dating him why would I want to date him. But
anyway I guess
she threw caution to the wind gave the phone number and eventually they ended up dating and
she realized my dad was a really nice guy and he ended up getting married and
thankfully they did because I wouldn't be here otherwise.
You know they will survive and live a first there know they lived at thirteen
sixty Ogden Avenue in the
Bronx and. They had an apartment there and they lived there for a
while and. Eventually they felt that they needed more space and they wanted to be closer to
family especially my dad's side of the family I think my father had a long commute go to work with
the
transit because he was working out of Brooklyn he had traveled from the Bronx down to go to Brooklyn every
day so they contacted my Aunt May
who is a beautician and a iness one B.
salons and she put them in an apartment on what they have in you and seventy seven
street but it was right over the boiler. So in the winter they love the apartment because they
had wonderful heat but in the summer it was like baking in an oven it was just too hot.
So eventually they ended up moving they found a place on what Hamilton
Parkway and they moved in compliments of the Silverstone's who are very like nice
couple who would rent from my parents because you know a lot of times people don't want to rent
to Irish Catholics hate to say it but they were not looked
upon
as good renters. You know but they got along wonderfully well with
the Silverstone's they were wonderful couple and they treated my parents lovely and we lived in their
you know their house or apartment I should say was over store and that's a
very sad story too. Because the people downstairs they had the store at the time they were the
Rosen's and Harry rose and one night was leaving work of one hundred sixty two got
on the Belt Parkway. And was driving his car
home and the car stalled out in the rain and he had run out of gas on the
Belt Parkway which is a big no no he got out of the car and he went and got two dollars worth
of gasoline came back with the gift tank over the the gas. Somebody call it.
The little plastic refill gas thing. And as he was pouring the gas into the car
he was struck by another car and his subsequent subsequently killed.
So out of that tragedy. His wife was sitting Shivah
which I thought Tom I never knew as a little kid what Shivah was she sat on a box
and she tore her clothing and she was mourning the loss of her husband my mom came
down to pay her.
Respects and out of that my mother eventual we worked with her and she bought
the lease out and she opened up Gallagher's candy store at seventy one alive and for health
and
parkway. And they own a store for about eight years but they worked really hard they were up at four o'clock in
the morning and they worked ten o'clock at night so it was long hours but it was very
profitable and together my father mother worked in the here and they really
did they really did a lot and it was interesting we had wonderful memories of the candy
store like. Well coming home from school I was never
hungry that's because when I would start off with a double dog and eat
that and I had a ring ding and then of wash it down with the you home
and after that it was a Milky Way bar and a Musketeer vodka and wash it down with a Coca-Cola.
So by the times in a rolled around you could say I was fully Tanger.
But they were happy memories there were good memories
and we got to read the comic books and we got to look at the Bride magazines
so there were lots of things to do. And of course we helped my mom in the store we washed all the
glasses the wash down the counters we filled up the candy for her and also took a
little for
ourselves and it was lots of things to go there was always something and I could wait on customers and that's how I learned
my subtraction or my addition had it in my head and how to subtract because we had a very old
cash register and it was unlike today where you put the numbers in and it does everything for you and it
prints the receipts and it tells you how much change. I was able to make change in my head and that helps me in
school
with my now my.
What are some of your earliest memories of the
neighborhood the earliest memories of the neighborhood I guess were wonderful ones
I remember going out on my bicycle I had a red bicycle given to me as a Christmas gift and we could
ride around the neighborhood and there was no such thing as cell phones.
You had Johnny's mother yell out the window and Johnny come home. Oh
I'm no cell phone then the next neighbor would yell Johnny your mother wants
you and the next neighbor would be. So was like a telephone system but it was all mothers
that were home or fathers that were home. Shawn a good older for if was agreed to
board. You know and then the kid with their own and then the kid would cycle home or roller
blade not roller blade he would roller skate home I'm sorry roller blades came much
later and. Everybody would play stupid all at night they would play.
Red Rover Red Rover come over they would play all different types of silly games but they were fun games and
they were active and everybody was
out you would sit on the stoop in the evening after you had finished your tours for the day
and parents would watch the children play or play in the street it was safe. You could ride to
the park and go around the park on your bicycle and you didn't have to worry about being harmed or
anything because basically everybody knew each other it was the sense of good community
good
neighborhood and a happy time. It's a happy time. I mean I know today people have their
cell phones but they don't seem to interact with each other anymore they're always busy texting and looking
down and at least when we played we played with each other we would argue
with each other we've fight with each other but we're still friends the next day you
know. If you have a problem with someone go to the park you would settle it. And
you would shake hands at the end today. It's a whole different ball game people you
know are a little bit more prone to violence.
You know they don't settle their arguments with the handshake they settle it with a gun so there's a whole big different world
out there very different from when I grew up was much
nicer and you have memories. The classmates that I had back in
that day when I graduated from any from today we're all on Facebook so at night
you can tune in which your
classmates from forty one I don't even say the forty some odd years
ago and we did have a reunion after twenty years and out of the class of one hundred
sixty we had about one hundred twenty kids show up for the
reunion and then a few years ago we had another reunion after forty something years and it
was about sixty people or so that showed up for the reunion. So it was
nice. Well it's nice to keep in touch and it's nice to have that come right away that
sense of friendship. You have to so many years. You know and they're all over the summer in
Massachusetts summer in
Florida and yet every evening you can still touch base with them and that's one thing I like
about Facebook most technology I don't like. Facebook. That's OK.
You can easily. Yes I have a sister June. She's so blind. She's
very involved in art she has always been an artist since she went to Parsons College of Art and
Design and she had put a studio apart on the top floor of her house
in Staten Island she subsequently sold a house in Staten Island.
She sold her mother in law's house in Park Slope on fifth
street and they moved to Cape Cod Massachusetts and now she
has look at Gallery of Art going up there and currently she's working
on metal sculpture like a welding and different types of
sculpture mostly her medium used to be like oil or
water
color. You know.
And where did you go for well if the Seine firms I went
totally Perpetual Help high school that was for years and
now all ph is shut down this was a girl's Catholic high school that's no longer in
service. And then from there I went to the four best years of my
life Brooklyn College I had a wonderful wonderful time a broken college and excellent.
I got to meet people from every walk every background of wife and I felt that was such a
great diversity there and I felt comfortable there. The people were very accepting
very far. I still have to keep in touch with my friends too from Brooklyn College.
So I've kept friends from high school college and from elementary school though I've
been blessed and then I went to graduate school at Brooklyn College also and.
One of the things I did was take to see you and why did that thirty above they have to
my masters.
When we went to England we were. To London North Polytechnic and we went to
view
students learning about science lab in England so Brooklyn College has a
lot of amazing things that they can do with with their students and they offer a lot
of courses and wonderful things I think people should take advantage of the cumi and the
Sunni definitely
because they are remarkable and you get a lot of bang for your buck I mean I think I went
through maybe two or three thousand dollars for undergraduate
and for graduate school I think it was like maybe twenty five
hundred or something like
that it was dirt cheap and it was the best education honest to God
and I ended up using it because I went through college and
graduated with my Bachelor of
Science and then I graduated my Master of
Science and I became a special education teacher my background is
neuropsychological brain disfunctions working with children and have learning
disabilities and I've been teaching now for almost thirty eight years on thirty
six years at my current school which is McKinley I have to find knowing on seventy three zero
one what Houghton Parkway run by Janice Kerry an excellent principal served under fourteen principles so
I know what I'm talking about but she's a lovely lady and wonderful
school. What. I
think
ironically. It can be said that the abuse that we suffered in the Catholic
school at a young age their grade in fourth grade was
hideous and I felt that no child should ever
be of use for a bully physically
mentally or emotionally and unfortunately that did happen in
my I would say second grade third grade fourth
grade and I felt that I could do a better job and I wanted to be a teacher so I can make
sure that the children under my care would learn and not be
abused and that's I know sounds terrible but that's the reality of
it. You know. What I've read in the
area regular
up. Well actually I started off I worked at P.S. one of two hundred
seventy second ridge Boulevard they gave me a place that was called T.M.R. which was trainability mentally
retarded in those days they don't use that word anymore. They say mentally challenge or
edge a complete
challenge. And I was working under Miss Mary Conners who is the principal
there and she said to me you know I want you to go back Sheila to Brooklyn College and I want to get
your master's in learning disability and become a resource on teacher and I said Huh. What's that.
And lo and behold I did exactly what she told me to do and then after
that I had worked also in one of four to adopt a more school then
ninety second and fifth. I worked over at. One ninety two
on forty seventh Street in eighteenth they haven't you know I didn't like that school that was my first year
teaching to tell you a million stories about the kids in my class it was really
sad and eventually I after I graduated I went down to one hundred
attorney street and I met my professor from Brooklyn College. Her name is Elaine Thompson
she she took my thesis my master's thesis for me and she marked
it and I walked into the room and she said Sheila what do you don't hear I said that's a talk so what are you doing
here says I'm giving out jobs I said who will suffer a fine line. So we went to
a book and they opened the book and it was shuffling to the boat
and she said where do you live and I said I live you know at that time I lived in my aunt's house on five
thirty five seventy fourth Street and I told her and she was all that's district what and I so it's
all district twenty I know and she let me see should not only have one school
in District twenty you don't want
it I said to what is it and she said you know wanted junior high school and
you know those junior high school kids forget about it you don't want them. No way.
So I said Well could you look it up and we pulled out the red book at that time there was a red handbook that had all the
school listed and she flipped through and she looked up the number and she says something called a will.
I said McKinley and she said yeah and I said she was Do you know what I said
oh yes I'll take it and don't I got my papers and went to
see my principal you design going to get her to you you're not staying on not
having your son to me I pick my own people you are not picked by
me I said Trust me you'll grow him of being I said don't worry that I'll work really hard.
I'll be the best teacher ever. And I'm going to be watching your morning own and night I said
OK no problem watch me. All you want. Then I said you can put a webcam in the wrong i said i'm gonna be busy
working you can do whatever you
want long ball he danced my wedding.
Oh ho ho ho. So I need to say Mr Don Angelo I did say.
And needless to say I'm still there thirty six years later. OK
So you know you can you know you can say I mean he couldn't kick me out I mean I worked
hard and he grew to like
me so Rajamouli So but yes he did like me in the end he danced with me at my wedding
so I think that's cool. It was a good man but very strict on my going into
very strict. But you could survive that you could survive anything you know I think all the principles
that came behind him were like a piece of cake compared to him.
What have been your biggest challenges is really biggest challenges. I
think I think the one
thing that I would have to say is the change in the discipline code.
I believe when I first started working was much stricter we had a very clear code
of discipline and children knew exactly what would happen to them if this
they did this the repercussion was this they did that the repercussion was that. But
today for whatever reason I think it has watered down quite a
bit and the teacher themselves even though we have two Deans of
discipline very nice ladies they work hard but I don't feel
the children can make that connection like. They they are. They are feeling that
there is no follow through or no repercussions if they go ahead and do something. That's wrong if they break
the
rules then you know they feel like it's more nebulous it's not
as clear cut as it was years ago. Like you know to lateness is equals one
cut two cuts equals one referral one referral means a trip to the dean.
Everything was very delineated today you can't even write a child up you have to
show fifty five ways that you have tried to contact and take care
of this child and coddle this child before you can put on paper anything that the child has done in
terms of misbehavior. And I think that's wrong. I really don't I am opposed to that I think
children
need to know that when you do this there are clear and concise consequences for
your actions right away. Don't wait ten months down the road and tell me this is your
now this is your
consequence because it doesn't there's no connection there you know and I think that's a problem. I
think discipline today is as a major problem because people don't want
to follow through on it or they tend to glide
over some of the things that the child doesn't the child feels oh I got away with this and this let me try this
and it gets further down the road instead of nipping it in the bud the discipline is definitely
key
area and are there any moments in your career and particularly proud of.
Well I would say yes I have been very happy to work in the school and
I've had some achievements along with certain students they have cheese quite a bit I had a girl a
few years ago who came in and was in like Dire
Straits and she was having a lot of problems a lot of issues and
it turned out that her father came to see me and he was a lieutenant in the police force in
Staten
Island and. He he got custody of her he went to court applied for custody of
her he got custody of her and he said to me I've never had a girl and I've never had like eleven or
twelve year old girl before what do I do with
her so I went through a whole thing list with him you should do this and this and this and
this. And so on telling him about it and eventually she ended up.
Making our study our society she got eighty five and above in all her subject areas.
She did really really well and she went on to a good high school in Staten Island and I was
very proud of how cheap MN You know she had come
in in a in a very sad fashion you know her mother was really unable to take care
of her and could working together with Dad we were able to get her up on her feet
and get her going in she was OUR a female and she loved all she loved
reading she was really a wonderful child she blossomed she really blossomed so she
was certainly a definite positive
factor in my career and with all the students along the way too that had emotional issues and things
like that and constantly pushing them along. I was able years later
to
sneak them and have them tell me you know hey you know I turned out pretty decent I did good
and I remember you and I remember your class and I was happy to be a part of it.
So that's that I think in and of itself is a plus you know.
And there are many highlights. You know many children through the years that you service that you'll probably
never know about and hopefully all of them you will wish the best for all of
them and you try your hardest for all of them and many of them are successful many of them do turn out
to be good productive citizens and I think that's the blessing of being a
teacher. What is it about this
particular area neighborhood which you spent most of your life and that is unique.
What is unique about Bay Ridge Well I think that I think that for
a long period of time when I was growing up
parents and grandparents still lived in this neighborhood and it was that home. Connection that even if you
travel far away. You could always come home to be a bridge and that was the beauty of
it and when you came home you felt like when you walked up or down the street you a bump
into neighbors and family members and friends that you hadn't seen in a
while and even though the years have passed. You still made that connection so I think that
that's one of the positives of a
bridge and. I think that they rich. Has been a wonderful community in so
many different ways I think they're very loving very giving I think during nine eleven
that showed itself very powerfully around here. I and know that we lost.
One of our students. Eddie Graffanino he was a firefighter in nine eleven he went to
Macon when he was one of our students he
died and we have a charity every year we give out awards. His father comes
to the school and gives out awards another firefighter that delight to see me from see
his students in the forms with Dennis So
Burke and also to awards and things have been made in his name.
Of one of our Deans passed away some years ago her name is Dorothy Guerrero and she was a
phenomenal person I mean really loving calling and in caring and did a lot for
children and we have an award that's given out every year in memory of
her and also for many years we gave out in the word to George Rennes award he was a young
teacher non-school who died suddenly aged in this twenty seven or twenty
eight he had an asthma attack and he didn't have his asthma pump with him and he
pissed away on his way to the hospital but he was the band leader in our school and
he taught bands and he's a phenomenal young man and does an oil painting still
hanging in the school that shows you know his dedication to the
students and
to the the art of music you know and his name is George runs of
wonderful young men he died way before his time you know he's a very nice you know.
But there's a lot of things that connect people and they range and a lot of things that are special
about people and a ridge and
certainly I love living here and I've lived here the bulk of my life and I hope to
go on doing so and a lot of my classmates feel the same way as I do my husband doesn't he wants
to go back to Connecticut where he's born and raised. But I still say Brooklyn
is the best you
know and I'm happy to be
or what are some of these changes. Oh
wow
I would say probably stores mostly you know along what Hamilton
Parkway stores have changed a lot eighty six street the same thing
to. Basically people dying moving away you know you
see that over the course of time you don't see as many of familiar faces as you
once did you know when you go
places you don't bump into people like you did at one time so things change
and people do move away after their parents you know pass on sometimes they sell the house and
they move away. So you don't see as many of your colleagues and friends in Bay Ridge as you
once all of us to change and say.
And you tell us a little bit about going back to Ireland for the family
or what drove you to that.
Oh well you know it said I wish I had spoken
more to my mom and dad when they were alive but a lot of times people don't want to reveal their
personal feelings and things you
know but unfortunately father died when I was fifteen I did go back to
Ireland when I was eighteen twenty one twenty two and I did go back to
Ireland recently but my husband my husband had only been to Ireland once before when he was three years also
he really didn't remember Arlen very
much and now as an adult we went back in two thousand and twelve and it was wonderful to go
back you know to see the sights we went to Kerry. We went to the ring the Kerry.
We went to Dingle
Bay We travel to slow I go I got to see cool cold when my mother
was from we went to from Kiernan County
Leach or my dad was from we went to St Brigid's church we saw
where my grandparents to bury that's interesting because my grandmother died like
all these twenty six one hundred fifty two and my grandfather her husband died August twenty
sixth one hundred fifty nine seven years apart the same
day and that happened was about my great grandparents. John. BARTON
And Mira and Bridget
Cullen they died within twenty four hours of each other and they were buried together on
the same day. One had died of a diabetic coma and then when she found
out her husband had died she said I can't live without him she had a massive heart attack she
died and they both were various again on the same day. So there is an interconnection I find
it dates a very interesting one of my great great grandmothers
was baptized
a hundred years to the day I was
born so I found that interesting you know. And so there is a
connection I always feel with dates like the seventeenth is a strong dating or family
my or my grandfather great grandfather died on February seventeenth. My sister had a son born
on February seventeenth. My father was born August seventeenth.
My friend's mother passed away all of us and know her she
also was born on August seventeenth is like there's a lot of interesting things like the start line
and dates you see patterns repeat themselves
in family law I find that kind of interest my mother's obvious and. Oh you know one of a
great date and that was the one my friend Susan's my mother was born
then and I had my husband's seventeenth but his April seventeenth my mother was April seventh.
So they liked each other he was God and God I said although there you see you know I'm a Gemini
my sister is a Gemini but we don't see eye to eye her with two
different two different people completely. I think we're about twenty three and very
tired always then find a hero listening to the office life of silence at the
moment
no I think I talk to deaf dumb and blind but I agree I appreciate the ability
to do this and I think it is wonderful and I'm very happy to be here or thank you. Thank you.